President Trump is taking direct aim at
robert muller in the russia
investigation in a series of blistering
tweets over the weekend the president
question the fairness of the special
counsels probe now the new attacks
follow the Attorney General's firing a
former FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
chip Reid is at the White House with how
fellow Republicans are warning mr. Trump
to leave mr. Muller alone chip good
morning well good morning the president
in the past has avoided mentioning
Muller by name but that changed over the
weekend as he called him out by name on
Twitter that may be in response to
Muller's decision to subpoena documents
from the Trump Organization something
that in the past the president has said
would cross a red line everyone in the
White House has cooperate on this
assistant to the president mark short
echoed his bosses frustration at the
Muller investigation after more than a
year and millions and means of dollar
spent on this there remains no evidence
of pollution with Russia in a flurry of
tweets over the weekend the president
said the Muller probe should never have
been started and he attacked its team of
investigators claiming it was
politically motivated why does the
Muller team have 13 hardened Democrats
he wrote some big crooked Hillary
supporters and zero Republicans while
it's been reported that 13 of the 17
members of Muller's team are registered
Democrats the president did not mention
that Muller himself is a longtime
Republican as is the man who appointed
him Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein himself nominated by mr.
Trump on Saturday the president's
personal lawyer John Dowd called on
Rosenstein to bring an end to the
investigation I think that people see
that as a massive red line that can't be
crossed fellow Republicans urged the
president not to fire Muller if he tried
to do that that would be the beginning
of the end of his presidency South
Carolina Republican trey Gowdy said the
president's attacks sent the wrong
message when you are innocent if the
allegation is collusion with the
Russians and there is no evidence of
that and you're innocent of that act
like it White House lawyer Ty Cobb said
the president was not considering firing
Muller an attorney John Dowd said his
comments about bringing an end to the
investigation where his personal opinion
and not that of the
resident but also the firing of the the
attacks come in the wake of the firing
of the deputy director of the FBI and
CBS News has learned that Andrew McCabe
did keep memos of his conversations with
the president and in particular during
the period when James Comey the director
of the FBI was fired John Jeffrey hit
the White House thank you so much chip